welcome to the fword and if you're
hungry you come to the right place I'm
cooking for 60 diners in the fword
restaurant but every recipe is something
you can cook at home this weekend
they're simple they're seasonal and
they're very very
tasty on the menu tonight for our main
course benison with chocolate sauce
Bambi's never tasted so
good I've got two new trainees to put
through the meal can they stand the
pressure uh 1 minute uh Chef yeah make
this one the best one sweetheart yes I
will otherwise you're taking an early
shower yes
yes and J Corin and I talk manto man I
will admit between you and I yes I do
have a low SP
[Music]
count mother myad I love mother I love
my dad have all never had and
the my mother and my dad but I love my
mother and I love my dad want to have
all never
had
[Music]
okay St ready yes Neil ready okay let's
go first order six covers table 15 six
pasta yes six tlell six venison six
puddings Chef let's go Russell move your
ass yes yes Che this is not Blackpool
piir now big boy let's go yes after six
four more come on and why is the water
not boiling just added it turn up the
heat yeah put some tinf on top yeah
bring it to the ball rapidly let's go a
start of T night is a very very
delicious teelia wild mushrooms and wild
mushrooms this time of year is
absolutely perfect because it really is
now mushroom
season service please now what's the
secret behind cooking mushrooms cook the
thicker ones first and the thinner ones
later so that the ones that have too
much water more importantly let me just
show you grab a handful of mushrooms
okay just a few of each mushroom watch
the water that comes out
out yeah it's just
water we're using a mixture of wild
mushrooms including shitaki churo and
trumpet the more the reason wild
mushrooms are great is they have a much
more intense
flavor okay good hot
pan I soed the mushrooms with shalots in
a very hot pan to get a really good
flavor I start off with oil because
butter Burns too easily once the
mushrooms start to cook a knob of butter
finishes off the flavor
beautifully
my Brigade this week are Angie great to
have her back in the kitchen especially
being a woman this week Angie's joined
by Neil a we Scott in the corner but a
big talent and of course I've got my
right-and man Mark
Sergeant my two comies this week are
stoy from laner and Russell from
Blackpool on order four cover table 12
four tlell wild mushrooms four venison
four rhubarb crumble no answer stoy you
we we yes Che yeah come on I want to
hear you please let's go now St
pressure's on now yes Heat's turned up
let's see if we can cut it turn that
water down cuz the past is going to over
cook in literally seconds yeah yes yeah
how long stoy uh 1 minute uh Chef make
this one the best one sweetheart yes I
will otherwise you're taking an early
shower yes chef Russell and stoy are
just two of over 1,000 people who apply
to work in the f word kitchen I put the
best 100 through a weekend of tests and
challenges to find the 12 who would make
it to the
restaurant that looks like it's just
come out of a dishwasher
each week two trainees compete
head-to-head for a chance to win a job
in one of my kitchens stop what you
doing everybody hello stop what you're
doing each week someone has to go home
you're going home and you'll stay thank
you you are
stay clear clear down yes sweep the
floor but try to do it with some C film
over your mouth yeah g I love you today
say tonight in the kitchen it's stoy I
think it tastes quite nice she's a chef
of 14 years who's never worked as part
of a team I love seeing customers or
people that eat my food who seem to
think it did the right thing it hit the
right spot and joining her is Russell a
catering student from Blackpool whose
parents run a Chinese Takeaway who
tast that is actually really delicious I
definitely got a lot to learn and that's
the whole reason why I've come to this
competition is because I want to learn
from the best
people you tasted it yes chef yeah and I
think it's okay
Chef pasta's overcooked stop again right
taste it if you don't know that now you
should be in a kitchen you know that
right Chef pasta's Like Glue it's not
even it's got no bite to it it's lost
it's it's greasy it's it's not good
start again start again take the
mushrooms out four more tlell come on
Russell
please the pasta
goes in at the last minute even from the
heat of the mushrooms helps to cook the
pasta even more so it should be dipped
in there your hand should leave the
basket in out into the mushroom yes I
know not everyone has time but pad dough
is really easy to make just combine
flour eggs and olive oil in a food
processor remove a knead for about 2 to
3 minutes until the dough is smooth and
elastic wrap in clim film and chill for
at least half an hour the secret behind
making good p
is not allowing it to dry out so you
have to really move your ass right uh
stoy and Russell let's go first thing we
have is a nice flowered table roll the
pasta just to take a little bit of the
sort of weight off the pasta machine so
we just get it a little bit thin so it
starts to go through the machine okay
and let the machine do the work every
time it goes through the machine it goes
down a number yeah now to cut it fold it
nice and neatly but while we fold hold
it we just sprinkle it with
flour here we go up and round and then
from
there nice long length pasta look at
where we are you don't really want any
longer than that because you got to
think of the customers pulling it from
their bowl so let's go there shall we
okay yeah take the Telly one piece
through back of the hand in the machine
yes up and look here it comes it's
almost like going to the hairdresser
isn't it that nice Fringe let those
little bits dangle off and then dry on
to there yes there we go let's
go nice very
nice the most important thing about the
presentation with the tlell of mushrooms
is get your tongue and twist the tchell
round so it almost shapes a really nice
ball in the center of the plate then get
your wonderful sauteed mushrooms oozing
of garlic and shots and just let them
sort of fall on top of the tagl telli
but the secret is to make sure the t is
not all broken up just like that nice
and relaxed parmesan cheese on there
quickly
yes let's go
sty move over that's it there there you
go got to be on your toes in the kit you
know that yes sir yeah you're heavy
footed like a little baby elephant
running round Clump Clump Clump Clump go
table two please go go go go go four T
Telly how
long after that four more tag tell away
please
hello hello hello how was the techn tell
of wild mushrooms it's very nice bit
seasoning a little bit more seasoning
bit more seasoning I thought it tasted
amazing the pasta the mushrooms the
garlic the herbs unbelievable all so
many taste in one go andly was amazing
very nice I wouldn't attempt it myself
but it was it was very good nothing was
overpowering but you could taste every
individual ingredient it was really
beautiful next on the menu along with a
main course of benisa with chocolate
sauce I poisoned my best friend the
campaign continues to get women back in
the kitchen wait tell the neighbors the
kitchen's been
used and more fun down on my
farm no no more no
[Applause]
more we're going to start cooking now
guys yes clean out that pan
yes welcome back to the f word the food
CH that's good enough to eat next up is
the roasted venison on a bed of creamy
cabbage with a red wine sauce finished
with bitter
chocolate Okay sto you with you
understand what's going on yes chef you
you got four in plus six is 10 now I
want five one of those five is for the
food critic good girl let's go get rid
of the fat in there please yeah yeah
let's go in the oven venison is not just
for Posh people like J you can buy it in
Supermarket so go on try it at
home
[Music]
a lot of people get a little bit worried
about venison cuz they think it's sort
of very gy and very strong but it's not
salt
pepper hot pan olive
oil
seal
butter
base
butter paper it protects the venison
keeps it really nice and moist nothing's
drying out they are the perfect Chef
blanket hot oven 8
minutes red wine chocolate
sauce Panetta shalot garlic be quite
generous of the black pepper corns
because we need to wake the sauce up a
bit time bay leaf
350 Ms red
wine the red wine gives it body texture
and a real nice depth of flavor
[Music]
reduce 350 Ms brown chicken
stock
redu beautiful
SI then a little dash of Ras vinegar d
chocolate delicious
[Music]
sauce don't slice it too
thin slightly pink in the
center loiner venison with red wine
chocolate sauce
done the combination of chocolate and
red wine may sound a little bit weird
but they really do go well together and
it's very rich so you don't need a lot
of
it when grating the chocolate into the
sauce whisk it in gently But be sure not
to boil the sauce otherwise there's a
possibility it will curdle if it does
start to curdle then change pans quickly
into a cold pan to bring the sauce back
together okay with the venison we're
going to serve a cream Cabbage yes yes
okay so it's cabbage with SLC carrots
and Panetta and the SLC gives it a
little bit of sort of you makes it sort
of taste almost like the garden you know
it's a root vegetable it's grown
underneath it doesn't see any sort of
daylight so it's all underground so the
flavor is extraordinary yeah
okay the vegetables and petta need brisk
frying for 4 to 5 minutes before adding
the cream and we go around the outside
of the pan okay all the way around so by
the time it hits the center uhhuh yeah
it's all nice and thick that is a dish
on its own let alone the venison to go
on top
into your
bowl creamy winter cabbage with slay
okay good okay Angie six Benet on here
stoy six on there please yes after that
you followed by four yes sauce please
that's nicely cooked
an nice and pink sauce please come on
Russell automatic now come on think
about it come
on
go please that six you just sent there
were the best come on let's go
yes did you enjoy your starter wasn't
bad wasn't bad it was it was lovely cold
plates though the someone's got to be
fired in there cool down a little bit I
like it piping hot would have been nice
if had so how's the campaign going to
get women in the kitchen campaign's
going fantastically well good good to
the extent that 2,000 women apply for my
help but there was one woman who stood
out from the rest she didn't even know
where the kitchen
[Music]
was kieran's a professional rugby player
so his diet is really important to how
he plays and how he trains and I don't
really help him in that area at all good
see nice to meet you one thing I hate
the most that's him having one over on
me so and the cooking thing is the only
thing he's got on me at the moment so if
I can match him in that area we're going
to be pretty equal now you look
Immaculate manicured and sort of almost
like you've never broken sweat you're
probably right fingers are soft nails
are just immaculate yeah yeah tell me
why can't you cook everything seems to
go wrong for me when I cook I either
undercook things overcook things get all
the the timing's wrong just nothing ever
seems to work out for me in the kitchen
she's cooked one or two meals and worst
disaster uh worst disaster put in one of
a friend at the hospital I poisoned my
best friend you poisoned your mate I did
by giving her uncooked chicken and she
spent two days in hospital oh my
goodness me so today we got all the
rugby players coming around for lunch
I'm trying to think of something that is
simple yeah sophisticated and something
that can sort of serve a large table
yeah and something that can help get
your confidence going in the right
direction and it is just a good old
fashioned fish pie oh my god I've never
ever touched raw fish there you go nice
hand full of prawns what do they feel
like
disgusting God dear oh dear you see what
I'm trying to do is get you dirty I'm
dirty enough right there you go what I
want you to do is just take the salmon
cut it in
half watch your fingers there right into
nice big long lines and then from there
and that's a dice I I hate if kieran's
light better at something than I am
so that's quite healthy that the fact
that it's competitive you know that
definitely he would be so surprised if
he came home from training and there was
a stunning meal sitting on the table
that's fish talk right really good
healthy fish stop what does that need in
there salt yeah good let's put half of
it in there
okay give it a little stir now we don't
want to stir it too much what happens if
we stir it rapidly what happens to the
fish the fish is just going to break up
break and
crumble fliping NE you've just started
to
sweat hold it down and toss that's it
there good good so now we got two things
going on at once great yeah you're
searing off the mushrooms you're cooking
off your fish y f what's that smoke
alarm smoke alarm has it ever gone off
before no flipping there's Hallelujah
where tell the neighbors the kitchen's
been
used the kitchen's been
used okay
great good try and get the salmon yeah
throughout the dish so it's really nice
and look there's nothing worse than
having a pie that's missing filling the
nice thing about this we don't need to
season it why don't we season it because
we've seasoned it throughout exactly
okay the smell of that yeah we haven't
even finished cooking it yet smells
great a nice tip when you're not too
sure is just dust your top yeah put that
down there's your mark yeah it's almost
like creating a little football pitch
look there you go now you know what size
the roll to and if you want the widths
one there one there there you go that's
where you got to stick with
it bit further up cuz you'll be short
there right there good look at the color
of those fingernails oh god what
happened there's flour there's salt
there's salmon there's monkfish there's
Cod there's peas there's onions there's
parsley there's stuck in there okay
lights on and hopefully they're going to
rise just turn that up a little
bit I saw they're here when was the last
time you had 10 big dudes like that set
at the table I've never had that many
people sat around my table be careful
not to destroy the pastry okay now leave
that one in there cooling down okay
tasty fish
pie
this was for you dors g happy very happy
Stace happy I'm really happy do you
remember we said about the competitive
streak earlier yes I think I've matched
him highly competitive uh cheers um
wasps I mean
sorry hi guys to see nice to see you
good to see you have you done anything I
have you have changed my life oh no no
oh babe hey what have you cooked I've
cooked to roast dinner serious chicken
pie chicken pie as well as a roast lunch
Karen's pretty chaff to be honest Ser
yeah and good or yeah brilliant
brilliant she know thinks the cooking is
not just a household Shore it's kind of
like she enjoys it so happy all right
guys it's really important okay that
hopefully you'll go back to your kitchen
you go back to your kitchen and you'll
go back to yours and do some cooking
surely I hoping you'd go and see my my
girl and uh give her a few lessons as
well you want me to go around and see
your lady and
well cooking I think you should do some
cooking for her no yes you know I'm
really pleased the fact that you've got
the confidence back you're cooking and
you feel really comfortable with it
that's so important I'm just more
confident in the kitchen that's great
now when's the next England match coming
up got their first game against
Australia I think it is so it's exciting
time again so we stuff them with a
cricket please give it to them from
behind again for the rugby yes and then
after a successful match random Madam's
here for chicken p fish pie roast lunch
do it good luck keep it up please good
to see you thanks for coming guys good
luck well done Stace Stace keep it
up Charles Gord is it is it really true
that 2,000 women responded to your
campaign I don't believe that yes it's
true but it's actually over 2,000 you
know that but what shocked me more is
the 70 women that asked you out for a
date they didn't yeah they were why did
they want to do that they got no
you clearly think they don't 70 women
yeah it's very strange let me just
introduce you to something put that in I
don't know if I should do this hi chares
my name is Nikki I'm 28 years old and a
classical pianist I'm looking for
someone who's creative zest for life if
I could cook for you it'd be roasted fet
of beef with porini and loads of herbs
wrapped in pahan and we finished with a
rich dark chocolate cake with raspberry
cie fresh mint and only one spoon cuz
we'd be sharing Charles my name is Sam
I'm 38 I'm a director of sales for hotel
consult and I'm looking for someone
spontaneous and who doesn't take
themselves too seriously who hopefully
shares my love of food no they're not in
public hi Charles my name's kit 57 years
old embarass I'm looking for someone
articulate intelligent and
sexy this isn't what I signed up for I
thought it was a classy food show if I
were to cook for you it would probably
be my very special smoke fish pie with a
rich creamy buttery
sauce there were only three of them
though weren't they weren 70 can I see
the other 67 not that there was anything
cuz they were really lovely now you've
clearly been a big hit with the women
watching are you sure your sperm counts
up to
it are you taking the
piss well I wasn't sure which is why I
going to have it tested chefs have a
genuine reason to having a low sperm cam
why are they where you stand in the
kitchen you're very close to the stove
and the heat that's generated from the
stove is not good for the old testes my
it Cooks them so is you you got a low
sperm count I will admit between you and
I yes I do have a low sperm count it's
got a low sperm count however he may
have a lot of restaurants but he got no
sperm it's fired three times and worked
four this week I've been worrying about
my sperm count as everybody knows sperm
counts are down due to diet due to
environment due to all sorts of things
men are seeking fertility treatment more
often than women uh men are in all sorts
of trouble all over the Western World
emasculated depressed doomed what can we
do about it as a food person I want to
know can I change the way I eat to
improve my sperm counter give me a
better chance of creating future
generations to find this out I'm going
to go head-to-head in a challenge for
manliness with Gordon and Gordon is a
hamster now according to recent
statistics this hamster on average is
likely to have a higher sperm count than
me pound for pound or more likely ounce
for ounce or fluid ounce for fluid ounce
what I want to find out is if I change
my diet radically and Gordon is free to
change his can I boost my sperm count
and beat him in a test of ility I think
jles has set himself an enormous task uh
hamsters testicles are about a quarter
of their body size and they produce far
more sperm than the average man these
days U men have over the last 50 years
men's sperm count has dropped
dramatically so for my money I'm on the
hamster right so it's the moment of
truth now it's the fertility clinic I'm
going to make my deposit uh and then
this specialist is going to tell me what
lies in future for me uh a sticky
version of palm reading basically
thank you gosh I do hope I can deliver
under all this
[Music]
pressure am I doing it in the Bog this
is terrible can't I go in the ladies the
very least there sort of fre on the
whiff of perfume in the
[Music]
air well I I don't really know what I
was worrying about there it's uh the old
magic is still there hi Giles I've got
the results eight out of 10 but they
could be 10 out of 10 really yeah count
64 million so that is really really good
in terms of um motility very very good
Vitality 73% that's like an a 73% isn't
it now the one area that is okay but not
brilliant which is borderline is
morphology and what the morphology shows
is the shape and the structure of the
sperm okay and yours is 14 which is
borderline which means it's on the Lower
Side
borderline that little hamster is not
going to get the better of me so next
week I'm going to be in the studio with
Zeta finding out what I can cook up to
improve my sperm count you will die
childless my friend I will father
Generations that's more than I ever need
to know about jles corin's Tad
Poes next on the menu pudding's not
looking too promising Chris when it's
brown it's cooked when it's black it's I
almost make my favorite French frog
croak it's awful this disgusting and the
children have to face a harsh reality on
the farm if the medicine doesn't work
Gary it's going to have to be put
[Applause]
down welcome back to the FW right sty
four nice vs and they were lovely yeah
beautifully cooked to be a great come in
a brigade not only do you have to be
passionate but you have to be willing to
work harder than most people do in their
entire lives you understand what's going
on yes you got four in plus six then I
want five more in I sent J Corin our
resident slacker to go and spend a day
in one of my restaurants to see if he
really does have a full day's work in
him a working day for a comei here
starts at 8:00 a.m. and ends at midnight
the starting salary is a magnificent
14,000 a
year right well I've got to the conort
I'm going to go in and meet Angela
Harnet and the team and find out just
what it takes to be a chef in a Gordon
Ry restaurant and for me a complete
first I'm going into the tradesman's
entrance hello so there how many are in
today then full I'm full for lunch and
we got about 150 tonight right that goes
like that you're not Gordon I'm
presuming as a restaurant critic you
know what this is I don't know like a
white radish or something well it's
basically the aroke family salhi you're
basically going to peel the whole lot
down in lemon water this all yes all of
this this is just one of about 20 jobs
you've got
today my Doom in the shape of a shot
each week Angela and her team chop 4,000
onions they produce 15 gallons of soup
and serve a total of 2,000
meals I feel joyous that Giles is in the
kitchen cuz it's sort of a little
revenge on critics you know they'll
suddenly realize how hard it is and how
tough it is and they can sit up there
and go yeah it's easy they haven't done
this they haven't done that but actually
come in the kitchen and do it you know
do a full day graft you know with the
pressures that you have to do day to day
and then tell me that we don't we you
know we're not infallible we're not the
pope for crying out loud
your next job is uh fish bones like I
said it's all the going I have to say
these fish these fish look the way that
I feel get rid of all the gills and take
out the
gut the conort serves 500 portions of
fish a week that's a thousand eyes some
terrible bloodthirsty sod has to gouge
out this is is so I'm never going to eat
in a restaurant again be a film critic
we basically put him on Ro crant cuz if
you can't manage fish you should be able
to manage that at least what does it
mean to be working with such a
high-profile Chef you everybody wants to
know what you're up to whenever you meet
your friends your family they're talking
about what's going on then I'll learn as
much as I possibly can in order to in
the future do what to have a nice little
restaurant or Country House something
like that in your I've been peeling
onions now for what feels like days and
I got to tell you it's not the hardest
job I've ever had but I'm losing the
will to
live
right let's go Giles wait come on I got
thingy to get for lunch and you're
pissing around let's go you move you
speed up a bit you're in service now and
you're basically in everyone's way to Du
lamb and a venison yeah after that we
come back to 29 lamb do your codon a
monke y drain off the fat so basically
go around there get a shinoa drain it
off he's quite appalling I think you
know he's very slow you know he's not
methodical he doesn't work tidy so you
got to be honest really you know if he'd
done a trial today he wouldn't have got
a job
CL me it's daylight Fair Fair Point
Gordon uh it's hard work I smell of
onions and fat like an old hot dog I
wouldn't do it again in a thousand
lifetimes it seems that the world is
full of ambitious young boys and girls
who think that working for you is a
privilege but I am not one of
[Music]
them okay and first of all I can't
believe you fell asleep in Angela's
Kitchen never seen that before in my
life if a man needs a kip a man needs a
kip in my life when I want to sleep when
I'm tired I go to sleep not in a kitchen
J well I didn't ask to go in that stupid
kitchen it was your idea you were trying
to prove a point that I couldn't hack it
I had a kit wanted you to do a full
day's work that's all just get in there
and sweat and graft and understand if I
wanted to do a full day's work I'd get a
proper job wouldn't I serious did you
enjoy it I enjoyed it in a way I tried
to enjoy it I tried to whistle while I
worked and Angel was going who's
whistling stop whistling I mean what
kind of a workplace is that it's like a
prison so sto and Russell back there
okay are busting their nuts off do you
understand exactly what they're going
through now I certainly do what if one
them had learned the principle of
heating up a plate it might have even
been War oh you're never happy are you
but I can make sure the plates are in
the oven yeah back in the kit oh back in
your box
right right ladies and gentlemen yeah
how are we very good than you how was
your venison really nice yes not too
rich uh no I've never had it before and
it was really tasty and what do you
think of the idea with the chocolate
sauce and the venison didn't taste like
venant did taste like game it was very
soft and subtle and it tasted very much
like beef but it was it was a lovely
blend of flavors it was strong enough
but not overpowering as you'd expect
game to be and it was it was lovely it
everything worked really really well and
it was just done just perfect melted in
the mouth loved it I've eaten venison
before but nothing that ever resembled
this and it's not just flattery because
I'm being interviewed here it it really
is it it was absolutely wonderful
beautifully I'd love to know how we done
[Applause]
it now it's time for pudding each week
on the F-word a guest tries to beat me
with their recipe for a pudding today
it's Christopher Parker with his rhubarb
crumble if he beats me his dish will be
served to the F-word diners I think my
rubub crumble will beat Gordon's cuz
it's just going to be simple it's going
to be a nice traditional recipe but my
Nan's cooked for years my Mom's cooked
for years I've cooked for years and I'm
really good at and people like that
people don't like stuff too fast fany we
have a bit of custard on the top great
right Christopher how are you very well
how are you yes good now what's the
secret behind the crumble you must have
one ingredient up your sleeve that's
going to sort of help taste it help make
it taste better demera sugar to make it
crunchy yes cast the sugar to make it
sweet chilled Bowl so that the butter
doesn't melt too much okay very
technical there with the old hands you
look a little bit like Gary rose that
Ranger Tang this is a very
straightforward rhab crumble except
we're going to saute the rubab off in
some fresh vanilla finish a little bit
of butter and then just slightly
sprinkle it with sugar so it makes a bit
of a caramel and what you putting on top
of your uh crumble Chris um I think I'm
going to go for an old favorite that
Everyone likes um custards what are you
putting on no I'm just going to serve it
with some mascapone lemon mascapone
lemon mascapone yes just something a
little bit sort of I suppose not as rich
as custard but something a little bit
lighter I don't think my hand's going to
like yours you know this crumble mix is
actually quite interesting because we
got some hazelnuts in there some oats
some flour Dema sugar and then just a
very light sort of lemon zest in there
just to make a little bit more vibrant a
little bit sort of easier to eat um one
of the tricks of my n is to keep
everything cold so um keep your
fingertips cold before you need the
butter and also the bowl has to be
chilled then it can get moist so if you
wipe it the tea tow then it's not moist
then the butter doesn't kind of go into
a paste that you can still keep it into
a crumble cuz sometimes um if things are
warm and it gets a bit too soppy this is
a pickle Ginger and This Ginger here is
more associated with when you're eating
sushi but it's actually quite sort of
light in pickle and um it's got rid of
that sort of rawness and it's not so
sweet um Chris yeah it's burning oh um
yeah can we get some more rhar please
and Chris something we always remember
in a kitchen yeah when it's brown it's
cooked when it's black it's the Hobs are
like industrial Hobs they're too hot now
it's the hob now yeah nothing to do with
Nana nothing do with your lack of
concentration now it's the H it's your
fault you keep talking what was food
like um in East Enders in that calf oh
it's awful was it really it was awful
yeah who was the chef well uh the props
guys used to cook the food oh really um
and to all that credit they were quite
good but obviously if they cooked it
like half an hour before it could be
cold
y I'm just going to put the final
topping on top of the rhubarb and it's
actually quite interesting cuz the oats
absorb more of the juice than it would
be if it was just sort of flour and
butter and the butter gets it really
nice and crispy and the Oaks just start
to absorb all that flavor from rhar how
long bana's recipe um maybe
about 10 minutes at the most 10 minutes
okay did you take this long learning
your Lines no
no look at that nice homemade normal
rubab crumble bring it over I always
like to compare them just before they go
the okay well let's put them together
bit of a chef's thing now yours looks
like bird seed okay or cat litter cat
litter thank you I think mine looks nice
you know oldfashioned have you know that
you haven't tasted it yet yet you're
slagging it off yeah I know but I think
mine's going to taste better anyway cuz
got odd ingredients in it right ready
yeah here we go bab boy oh good luck by
the way can I have the um top shelf you
can have whatever shelf you wish like to
wish you the best that's just luck thing
and yours looks
awful
hello hi mate how are the turkeys doing
it's been a bloody tough week you know
that is it oh fellows they're not well
Gary not well that abscess has grown
it's not as easy to live the good life
as I thought we're fattening up six
turkeys for Christmas dinner but one of
them Gary has got an abscess on his foot
Peter the vet has been giving him
antibiotics okay now we've got to get
this down his throat the syringe has to
go right down the back of his throat
there and give it a
squeeze okay close his mouth let him
swallow there's he swallowed do you see
him swallow oh wow good
boy I can't believe my daughter's
kissing Gary joking aside it's time for
the kids to face a harsh reality if the
medicine doesn't work mhm Gary is going
to have to be put
down while the children wait for news
Gary they've been helping me in the
garden I'm growing fresh seasonal
vegetables to go on the plate with the
turkey I'm determined my kids will grow
up known where their food comes from
unlike one in three kids who don't even
know what chips are made of what's that
beet be
leak no in Italian Italian no
cavero right let's start again then
let's start again what's this one what's
that one leaks
leaks
one more
time okay this
one but the misses isn't as happy with
the farm it's wet it's muddy the turkeys
have begun to smell a bit even though
they're regularly cleaned out and the
kids just get caked in everything and it
it's not great um they're
everywhere um Garden's an absolute mess
I have to say I think the honeymoon
period is over it stinks how can I get
rid of that smell probably what would be
a good idea to try is if we spread straw
on this area for now and keep it dry
yeah um it'll enable the birds to walk
about on dry ground and what about put
them out into the garden and let them
spread their wings a bit I think it's
much better that these birds are allowed
out and give them some Freedom let walk
around don't tell Mommy okay please
Mommy oh no I told you so what's the
ladies on bird flu there are no
directors from def the people who
organize all of this um at the moment
because we don't have bird flu here so
free range birds are quite uh quite
happy to be out there's no problem there
so you're more than confident that we'll
still have free range turkeys on the
table on the 25th of December yes
absolutely there'll be free range Birds
um in the supermarkets for Christmas
unless the situation gets any worse
that's good news absolutely right come
here we're going to dry their pens out
we're going to scatter the pen okay with
some straw we get all the straw like
this
[Music]
yeah
this mega
no no no more no more I think they look
happy don't you yeah my back no more
your what my back your we shouldn't
throw hay around everywhere come here
she didn't throw on me I didn't throw it
dropped on you no you throw it on right
listen just tell Mommy okay she stepped
over it don't tell my I'm going to tell
her that what really happened no no no
listen listen listen some sweeties
yeah yeah Gary definitely seems to be
more comfortable on the straw and he's
been on antibiotics for a week so it's
time for Peter to make a decision about
whether he's going to pull through or
will he have to be put down hone what do
we sa Peter hi um right he's been on the
painkillers he's had
antibiotics he's clearly not eating and
it's Peter's
decision unfortunately whether or not
Gary stays with us Jack
till Christmas
or we're going to have to put him down
so Peter what do you think well I've had
a look at him today walking around but I
just want to have a look at his foot one
more time if you remember the base of
his foot was quite swollen yes um and
that's the important thing oh look and
that's softened now it's not as swollen
at all this joint is working quite well
and um when I was watching walking
earlier he was walking really well so
the good news is I think he's made it
and I think we'll take him off the
antibiotics and hopefully we're there
okay happy yes all right Gary staying
with
us Gary's going to be with you for
Christmas you got a turkey for Christmas
yes
yeah I have a little taste of mine yeah
okay and I have a little taste of yours
cuz I'm dying to taste it but you know
what I'm going to taste it without the
custard uh
Christopher it's not bad okay two out of
10 good luck good luck my man yeah yes
it's time for our rubab will be judged
and it's my reputation on the line so
far it's one win to the guest
cook oh get out and one win to me Mom
I'd never have won had you not taught me
properly you know that but I should win
hands down to this young upstart we've
chosen our judges from tonight's diners
and all that matters is taste now nice
put of cinnamon in there though like
that that's good don't know why I think
I can taste lemon juice but really maybe
maybe it's not maybe it's just the
combination but it's not quite t smart
enough this is your
aition this is totally the reverse it's
not quite as sweet either it's got a
nice little of touch to it it's got to
be dessert number two number two dessert
two so I have to say the winner he is
this week
yes what G in
yes what congratulations well done I did
I'm devastated no don't be devastated
three out three my n's not going to be
happy I'm gutted um I didn't like his
rub crumble I don't it was all right but
it doesn't taste like rubub crumble mine
tasted like good old fashioned rub
crumble I think those blind tasters I
don't think they were tasting it I think
they got mixed up somehow but what's
even worse is that all three of them
chose Gordon's and didn't choose not
even one of them like
mine next on the menu it's a treat from
Scotland it's like something out of
ananian f fil and we find out which
commi will be back and which one will be
going home for good so the person I'd
like to keep in the Brigade of the
[Applause]
fword time to find out what our guests
thought of their
pudding delicious very nice um fruity
flavors nutty top bit it was
bitter it was gritty nuty I don't like
nuts perfect in thir three C
delicious now um you're a bit of a food
connoisseur right I pretend to be yeah I
don't tell anyone I'm not you've sort of
almost tasted everything on the planet
within reason well I actually think I'm
beating you now no yeah I've tasted
something you haven't tasted can only be
a vegetarian lasagna not quite better
than that
ganet we're in a very remote and
inhospitable part of British house right
in the very Northwest tip of Scotland
just above the outer Hodes in search of
something unique and delicacy called
ganet a seabird that's notoriously
greedy the ganet is actually a protected
species the Islanders of Lewis are the
only people in the UK who are allowed to
kill and eat these birds but they're
under pressure from the animal rights
Lobby and it's probably my last chance
to taste this bird we're in search of a
ganet what that of delicacy what do they
taste like oh I'm Amber nectar Amber
nectar salt salty duck uhhuh fishy duck
fishy salty duck fishy salty duck this
is the rarest bird ever and I haven't
tasted one and I've been cooking for 20
years and I'm dying to get a hold of
this thing there's got to be somewhere I
can get hold of one well you're probably
going to have to try
Sweeney hi Gordon yes hi I'm Sweeny
Sweeney I understand you're looking for
some cooker it's illegal to buy or sell
ganet or gooa as it's known locally but
Sweeney was born in Lewis and he has
offered me one of his birds from this
year's Co having eaten nearly everything
there is to eat in this world I've never
ever had the chance to come across this
delicacy well I'll see you know it'll be
an expedience the Islanders Sal cure the
ganet which only adds to its
overpowering smell so Sweeney keeps his
in the garage not a good sign for
something I'm about to eat God the smell
what have you done to it it's just
oders Jesus Christ almighty it's like
something out of an alien film T oh God
look at the fountain it yeah and that's
been in there for how long uh less than
two weeks really but what's in that
liquid just salt so it's almost like a
Brine and this is the
delicacy that I've traveled hundreds of
miles across sea and land to look at
this worth your a while isn't it
oh for God's sake sween's no cook so he
sends me off to find someone whose
traditional ganet recipe has been handed
down for Generations go find
Mian that's for you for me because
apparently you know exactly what to do
so you're going to quarter it first yes
doesn't look very
appetizing traditionally this was cooked
as well but I I take this for
feet one two three four there we go and
that's it you boil it for an hour and 20
minutes to an hour and a half no salt no
pepper no salt no pepper no nothing just
pure and sneaky Baya in there or
something B time not a hope not a hope
not a hope the thought of somebody doing
something like putting a wine sauce or
something like oh my God you
know the cooking smell is rank Hy
hell that's worse than rotten eggs that
no it's not at all how long's that
linger for that I mean can you tomorrow
anyway to tomorrow let's see if this
thing's cooked there we are the wow
smell it doesn't smell as strong now as
it did when it first started cooking
told
you
fascinating having seen how it's cooked
I'm dreading eating it
we
anticipated that's incredible it's it's
so fishy mhm I mean it's absolutely
incredible it's a cross between a sort
of surv tuna stroke macaron and V and
and with a with a meaty flavor God it's
quite refreshing I didn't think it would
be that tasty you know that he told you
so there you go the meat is delicious
I'm not that Keen on the fat it's quite
no the fat yeah that's quite sort of I
much prefer rendering down and using it
for heating my
stove that's the F that's the meat have
meat I've asked Mariann to come to
London to share her recipe with the
F-word diners let's take it to our food
critic see what he's got to say yes here
we go now this is a rare delicacy yeah
have have a wee bite of something
historical no don't move away like that
taste it come on it smells of pickled uh
pickled
fish it's taste slightly of snake no
snake taste a taste a bit of this one
here no no no no cuz that's that's a
joke is what is that not a joke for
God's sake man it's stop being paranoid
have a taste what
it the skin of the ganet God almighty
it can't be worse than a raw Kebab for
God's sake that is a delicacy that's
like sucking the puss out of a a boil
come on I'm so sorry about my friend
being so rude about I'm so sorry I'm not
a very sophisticated don't care it's
it's better than the venison Jean
Baptist you're very cool and sve and
sophisticated get your mouth around some
Gan man yeah get some decent just e bird
inside
you and a bit of this one as well you
got to eat together you see this whole
thing is about being sve mine isn't so
he could be in trouble yeah it's called
Brill cream come
on did you take that out now open your
hand up there no put on the floor that's
terrible you spat out a ganet it's awful
you eat onet the inside of intestines in
your but onette tastes of poo whereas
this doesn't taste quite that nice
welcome to the f word now if you're
someone that cooks every night or maybe
someone that doesn't cook at all and
wish they could this is definitely the
show for you you on the menu tonight for
our main course brilliant red wine serve
with mashed
sarc Nigella the turkey has a weight
problem we're all getting very concerned
about Nigella is it normal for a bird to
be so big and one of my trainees looks
to France for inspiration who Raymond
Blan I can't hear you I'm sure you can
go who what's his
name here
the my mother and my dad love my mother
and I love my dad what to have all that
never had the the C my mother and C my
dad I love my mother and I love my dad
want to have all
[Music]
never
St uh Jean
Baptist excellent thank you I'll order
five covers table to five p P salad five
Brill today's starter is a very rustic
pigeon salad with a hazelnut vinegarette
and it has to be the most perfect time
of the year for Pigeon salad this is a
fantastic mix of flavors with the gy
taste of pigeon set off by the rich
nuttiness of hazelnuts the earthiness of
the beetroot combined with the oak leaf
lettuce wakey wakey now now it's the yes
understand what you're doing Don't Panic
don't rush yes but get a grip now you've
probably never cooked with pigeon before
but it really e e easy very
straightforward so go on have a go now
we're not cooking Town pigeons from
Chapala Square these are actually wood
pigeons that have led a much happier
live and obviously eaten from all over
the woodlands making them a lot tastier
[Music]
bird now the secret behind cooking the
pigeon perfectly is you've only got to
cook it between four and 5 minutes start
off on the skin color it and turn it
over then put your butter in helping us
cook tonight our two comies this week is
Danny is a 21-year-old from Essex he's
passionate about cooking and he's been
working in kitchens for six years he's a
chef at a pub brazer in Essex I just
really want to bless him my career I
want to be successful in what I do I
don't I don't want to work in a pub for
the rest of my life I want to work in
London's top restaurant and Phil he's 19
and he's from the WHL and has just won
WHL chef of the Year 2005 is that a good
thing I'll find out tonight I want to be
right up there at the top with the well
with the likes of golden Ramsey to work
in clares be massive I won't fill in
there doing that now I want fill in
there doing that now that's three times
I'm not saying it again yeah there you
go control it I want the oil nice and
brown not black fil and don't be scared
to take it off the heat when it's
getting too hot yes pigeon is a very
lean meat you know that very very little
fat in the center so be very careful
because if it's too hot you're going to
overcook it yeah it dries out instantly
be very careful Phil and Danny are
competing head to-head and at the end of
the night I'll decide who's staying and
who's going home now to finish the top
of the salad we've got cloves of garlic
that have been sliced very very thin but
that's too strong for this salad so
we're going to fry it very very
quickly once they're cooked drain them
from the oil and you've got these really
nice fine garlic chips okay start the
plate up yes a sh bowl dny that sh Bowl
start off with a nice little handful of
nuts quick gently gently okay beetroot
on top some pick coriander leaves in
there
coriander some beans in
there now don't get your hands in there
yet don't you dare get your hands in
there yet this is salad that dresses
itself rock salt Just a Touch in there
yes okay now watch you get the bowl and
you just roll it round I don't want
hands in there combine the salad the
beans nuts
coriander on let's go make sure it's
evenly distributed yes go good watch you
get the breast like that and you just
slice down almost like you're slicing
smoked salmon then you get your
vinegarette you just glaze over whil
it's still nice and warm yeah okay now
garlic chips you take a little handful
and you just scatter them around nicely
you don't throw them on there you just
scatter them around the smell coming
from that plate is phenomenal you happy
with that yeah good send it five salad
of pigeon Table Six please beetroot lots
more hazelnut yeah don't
skim
okay then how was the pigeon uh lovely a
beautiful fat really happy bird nice
wood pigeon not not a NY traga Square
thing really happy with it salad little
bit imbalanced I thought a little bit
Yeah the beetro I wouldn't walk a m for
but that was great and what about the uh
what about the turkeys what about the
Christmas dinner how that is that coming
along it started off as a really good
idea but it looked lovely on what I saw
but I didn't actually realize how much
hard work was involved in sort of you
coming to terms with growing your own
Christmas
dinner the turkeys are at War and poor
old Gary is coming off worse well you
know who pecks on him go on no jell jell
oh she pecks on everybody she pecks on
my bum I want to be sure the turkeys are
really fattening up Peter the vet has
suggested that we weigh them each week
hello everyone what do you say Peter
what I brought along with me today is a
spring balance spring balance and a bag
that we can put him in almost like a
fishnet that's right yeah okay and this
is a good way to remind the kids of the
turkeys are livestock for the Christmas
table and not pets two handles on the
side there we go there we go Anthony no
he's on
five let's get DEA 11 kilos ay is
running at 6 kilos
she oh dear Nigella doesn't seem Keen to
reveal her weight such a come on
what's that 12 and 1/2 kilo 12 and 1/2
kilo the B she is definitely the biggest
bird mate so de and Nigella are big
birds Jamie Gary and Angley need to put
on some
muscle and Little Anthony is the run to
the
bunch next morning we're out early to
feed up those
turkeys are they in are they in no oh
come on oh no oh come on D let's go say
good morning to the turkeys yes yeah
let's go up up quick Daddy no he broke
it
why it seems that the perch couldn't
take nigella's weight oh no Nigella I
can't believe she's broken the stand
Nigella nothing nothing nothing Nigella
Nigella scrapes Anthony's be Nell the
Troublemaker nigela is the big
troublemaker's very nauy
[Music]
Troublemaker I'm worried about n n's
aggressive behavior so I've brought in
some expert help we're all getting very
concerned about Nigella she's over 12
1/2 kilo is it normal for a bird to be
so big the the fleshy Parts develop much
more the crunk down here these are all
the bobbly bits this is the
wle and he's just got a little beard
here see that's just growing it's like
horse hair I can't believe nigella's got
a beard I think she's a man really yeah
she's not a Nigella she's an Nigel and
Nigella is not the only she that's a he
the other turkey's K unles and wattles
are a dead giveaway apparently so Nel is
a man Angel and Anon are girls that
means deia the big one next I mean that
clearly looks like a man I think it
should be Dennis actually it looks like
Gary is a man Gary is a man yeah which
is good news I think it's good news for
Gary now Jamie at the back is an
interesting one you sometimes get
turkeys that look as though they could
be either or sometimes does happen God
I'm sure whatever they sex they'll taste
delicious now good evening how are you
very well inde D than how are you yeah
that was the pigeon was fantastic I'm
enjoy I'd never had pigeon before and it
was really tender and really really nice
and the whole the whole all the flavors
mixed together the beetroot and the
garlic and everything it was it was
lovely I imagined that it would taste
like chicken but in fact it's a very
meaty taste it's it's very nice a bit
like beef in fact I didn't actually
realize you're such a foodie I love it I
really love love food absolutely now um
you're a bit of a lady's man yeah yeah
as a romance no but I mean would you
prefer taking them out for dinner or
would you prefer cooking a romantic meal
I think cooking a rantic meal is the the
best thing I cooked some wild salmon
recently wild salmon and just very
simple just um with some olive oil lemon
probably let Let It Down by doing mashed
potato with it which is real real
wild Sal who was that for um a friend
come
on what's her
name damn did she stay for
breakfast I'll see you later thank you
good to see you thank
you next on the menu along with our main
course of brilliant red wine was
disgusting there what what's all this
stuff we discover what's really in the
humble Supermarket sausage skin rain
gristle tendon
sen and Rod Stewart's fiance drops in
just weeks away from giving
[Applause]
birth ready Phil's gone yes every table
happy yeah four BR and four BR let's go
yes welcome back to the fword remember
everything I cook here you can quite
easily cook at home have a go wakey
wakey
please now time for the main course
which is Brill poach and red wine served
with Crush salc finished with a touch of
cream and roasted salfy table's going
down M people don't actually think about
cooking a white fish and a red wine but
it actually tastes amazing and it looks
fantastic when you cut into
it BR raise a sharp knife fill it nice
long slices that's the first one off
[Applause]
up Brill bones and turbet bones are the
most soft after in any kitchen that will
make the most perfect fish top skin and
just
pull this little bit here is called the
skirt that's lovely inside a fish Pine
it really is
delicious season both
sides red
wine thyme bay leaf garlic salt pepper
and and olive
oil
[Music]
poach the
sauce shot um it's a bit of a sort of
cooks thing really because onions are
far too strong a shot it's quite
mellow butter you get some real nice
color on there want this nice real nut
brown flavor on the
[Music]
shot
[Applause]
sugar really starts to caramelize those
shots beautiful shine on there rasy
vinegar
in and it just sort of wakes everything
up a little
bit add poaching
wine
reduce 50 g of butter shake it into the
sauce
fish slice onto the
plate Brill in red wine
sauce
done now when you fting a fish use a
very flexible sharp knife because let
the knife do the work and a brew like
this actually comes with his own
instructions cuz all you have to do is
follow the lines so we start from the
head and come in
cut round the
head and then just one clean sweep down
that line and just go all the way down
to the tail and look what
happens the knife actually Cuts away the
filp and then lay the fillet back on top
of the brill and just follow the knife
all the way through that's the first
fillet off literally two
sweeps every drawer should have these
four very simple straightforward knives
the F knife that does the work for you
that's a flexible blade that bends round
the bone on the fish and doesn't allow
it oh
me okay I I've just stabbed Danny
um have you got a plaster Neil I your
knife
okay to go with a Brill we're serving
two vegetables you may not have cooked
with before crushed salc bought together
with some cream and then some roasted
salsifi
salfy tastes like a cross between AR
choke and turnip don't overcook it as it
adds great texture to the dish I add it
to onions sated in oil a knob of butter
Browns them nicely and finishes off the
flavor now cerc is a very versatile
vegetable great as a puree even great in
soups and you can actually eat it
raw okay plates ready plates ready in
the r tonight is Rachel cook a
journalist who's passionate about good
food hello Rachel hello good to see you
how was your pigeon H it was delicious
yes thank you it was a wood pigeon yeah
not a pigeon from Chago square and so
you must um care about meat I mean where
your meat comes I've always cared sort
of not just for my own personal you know
benefit but obviously for the customer
benefit the fact that we give that level
of security to make sure that
transparency is there for them to
understand so you've been looking into
Supermarket Meats for us I have I've
been looking at sausages I've been
trying to look beyond the packaging to
see what actually goes into the
sausage in the UK we spend over half a
billion pounds on sausages every year
but do you really know how much meat
goes into your average economy Banger
and do you know what else goes in there
besides does it taste meaty it does
taste meat does it it looks a bit bendy
i' say it's about 70% 70% meat that is
actually an economy sausage from a
supermarket and it contains 32% meat I'm
appalled that a sausage can have as
little as 32% meat the rest of it is
mainly water and breadcrumbs by the way
but more shocking still is what that 32%
can be made up of when it says meat on a
label for a product such as a sausage it
doesn't actually just mean lean meat it
means other things like fat connective
tissue and connective tissue is things
like skin rained gristle tendon sen so
over half the so-called meat content can
be gristle and fat and it's still
allowed to be called meat on the label
it is safe and it is legal but if I'm
going to eat gristle and senu I want to
know about it and I think the current
labeling system is
misleading earlier this year Gordon and
his team of food technologists
investigated the contents of economy
sausages from the big four supermarkets
to see how much so-called connective
tissue they contained in total the
results are enlightening if not
surprising ring our research showed that
the connector tissue levels varied
amongst the supermarkets uh Morrison's
had
7.5% Asda 10% Sainsbury's 22% and Tesco
24% connective tissue so according to
tests carried out by Gordon earlier this
year the economy sausage being sold by
Britain's biggest Supermarket contains
the most connective tissue that's skin
rind gristle tendon and sinue to you and
me so how can you spot better quality
sausages in this Supermarket well
there's one very simple trick to
remember when buying if a packet of
sausages is labeled simply sausages like
these the legal requirement is that they
contain just 32% meat if on the other
hand the label says pork sausages like
these the legal requirement is that they
contain 42%
meat to demonstrate what all this means
in Practical terms I went to visit top
butcher moan and Suns winner of 12
awards at this year's National sausage
competition show me what you put in one
of your sausages okay this is the meat
here this is for an 80% meat content
sausage and how many um sausages would
you be able to make out of that meat
approximately 120 so Richard you're
going to help me make a sausage that's
just on the limit of the regulations now
I'm going to make 120 sausages this is
the meat for my sausages but doesn't
look like meat at all how much is that
what percentage this is a a 32% meat
contents sausage that looks disgusting
though what what's all this stuff um
well this is connective tissue you
allowed a quarter in in your recipe
right and um this is pork fat and you're
allowed 30% we've also got this is that
going in the sausage too yeah that's the
extra bits you know so long as you
declare it on your label then that's
fine so going into the barely legal
Banger is 32% meat which includes fat
and gristle then extra fat and gristle 3
kilos of rust and some coloring in
[Music]
herbs so here it is the barely legal
Banger technically it's a sausage and
under current labeling guidelines it can
be sold as a sausage um I I think the
law should be looked into just to
clarify what is actually called meat um
in my mind meat is really lean meat and
fat um I wouldn't really call Gristle
and and skin or connective tissues um
meat so how did our testers react when
they found out exactly what we put in
our barely legal Banger it's repulsive I
mean you can basically just get away of
anything but just by putting meat down
you assume that if it says meat you
would hope it's the finest cuts of the
best raised beef or pork now I think I
will go very oh my God that's
drastic so when you're shopping for meat
always read the label check the water
content check the percentage of meat
included but remember that with sausages
55% of the meat can be made up of fat
and gristle and that's in addition to
the fat and gristle that you'll find on
the label secondly if you're buying
sausages always look out for the ones
that are labeled pork sausages rather
than the ones that are just vaguely
labeled sausages they're more likely to
have more meat in them so if you're not
keen on connective tissue you might want
to think about which Supermarket you buy
your sausages from
that looked extremely Grim yeah quite
Grim what what are your sort of main
conclusions then after of that I think
there are two things first thing is that
the label may not tell you all there is
to know so read it carefully and if you
want less connective tissue in your
economy sausage then well I wouldn't go
to Tesco or SS spr now we'll put a
little bit of salfy on top of these last
ones yes so lift up the brill drain it
no no nice and gently lift it up okay
and the curvy side sits up okay so it
doesn't look upside down that's it good
lift it up drain off the red wine and
sauce generous on the sauce okay cuz all
the sauce is is the cooking liquor from
the
brill okay so that's why okay table Mark
please good very nice table eight gently
excuse me go table eight
good
the main course was was lovely I really
liked all the different flavors that
were going on well I thought I actually
thought the fish was really circulent
and the sauce um it really complimented
it well it was quite spicy and quite
Tangy it's really good um not so sure
what was underneath it was fine um I
don't know what it was but yeah I think
it really all went together quite
well
okay how was that it was it was
fantastic I love it it's all all kind of
dark purple then you cut in and it's
white bright brilliant white and you
have that smell of of red wine and onion
so you think you're eating steak and
then it tastes like fish and it reminds
you how meaty the brill is and and it's
it's slimming yeah now for some bizarre
reason last when we actually started
talking about your sperm count and my
sperm count it's amazing we must have
run out of other things to talk about it
was because it was because I discovered
that sperm counts are dropped off over
the last 50 years you know among males
all over the world uh and and and partly
because of diet and I thought I might
find out what my sperm count was uh and
see if I could do anything to improve it
with uh with what I eat I found out 8
years ago that I have a low sperm count
and last week jars went to have his
checked out
too well I I don't really know what I
was worrying about there it's uh the old
magic is still there his count was fine
but the sperm was slightly misshapen
yours is 14 which is borderline in the
last 50 years toxins in the food chain
have helped cause the average man's
sperm count to plummet more than 50%
Miss shapen or a mobile sperm is
increasingly common diet can play a
major part in increasing men's fertility
and top sperm Foods include nuts red
peppers cabbage fish and dairy and Zeta
yeah is there a crisis with men's sperm
there is um male fertility is definitely
on um The Decline and I think that men
are really neglected in this whole area
and do you really believe that a diet
can actually help increase the sort of
the sperm you know development
production yeah absolutely what kind of
things should they eat well the food
we've got here nuts um and seeds are
very very important rich in selenium
rich in zinc um oily fish very important
rich in um omega-3 DHA very important
for the head and the Tails of the sperm
and then um fruit and vegetables rich in
antioxidants vitamin C vitamin E protect
the sperm against damage from free
radicals uh is there something I can
specifically eat to to improve the shape
of my sperm yeah I think that the you
know the food here would be very very
good um alongside uh drinking plenty of
water um and life factors and in your
case J's you know a lot of alcohol if I
haven't drunk lots of alcohol how am I
going to end up in a position to meet
people and then you're not you're
clearly not listening to what Z said
stop drinking Gordon first of all can I
just say um I'm really pleased you're
here what exactly is the problem yeah
well I was told just coming up for two
years ago that I had poor spare motility
I produce spare but they don't go
anywhere and in that situation there'd
be no chance of a just having a baby AC
but is there any form of diet Z they can
turn Gordon's problem around and get
them moving and working well we I was
talking to Gordon over dinner about his
diet and you know we've discovered we
wasn't eating breakfast um but also
drinking a lot of fizzy drinks um which
contain lots of preservatives and
chemicals which you know aren't good
eating loads of crisps yeah and drinking
plenty of water I mean you know a lot of
men don't drink enough water and sperm
need to swim at the end of the day
you're not drinking the water you yeah
absolutely CH I've got a theory about
this particular sort of um low sperm
count because I actually believe
especially in the chef World a lot has
to do with the heat and being enclosed
in those confined conditions under that
amount of pressure and when you look at
the position of a stove in a kitchen it
really is online with your scotum I've
got my chefs to go and do a test and the
sort of results have been quite
fascinating um sge 2
seconds um so the sperm count how were
they um good sperm count but just you
know not not particularly um you know
well in motion and um um deformed heads
so like small narrow heads really yeah
and Cher is that to do with the heat or
is that um you know a common well these
Studies have shown that that it can
affect sperm what we call sperm
morphology the shape of the sperm right
it can affect the shape it can affect
the motility and it can affect the count
as well um but um obviously we we'd have
to do a study a proper controlled study
on Chefs and and actually
measure scal temperatures and these
sorts of things to see whether in fact
sure you are going to see so there could
be a possibility I mean on the back of
the you know history with the fireman
The Bakers I mean you know chefs may
suffer from that problem down the line
and personally now I'm going to do a
ring around and maybe come back to this
topic next on the menu the pressure's on
for my comies as they go head-to-head
over pudding will it be Danny's peir
creps or fills chocolate
fondant how dare you come to the FW all
those fighting right now and you want to
bring in a chocolate
fundan and jles Corin sinks the new
depths squirrel for his supper that's
the little front legs all little livers
and kidneys the heart and soul of the
squirrel mashed up high tasting quite
smelly in a little pie
[Applause]
case now it's dessert time and this week
we're going to turn up the heat on our
commies with Danny and Phil cooking a
dessert of their choice
Phil how are we going so what are we
doing uh doing a chocolate F mate yep um
between now and midnight I want you to
forget the word mate and just remember
the word Gordon cuz I'm not your mate
where did the idea come from uh Raymond
Blan who Raymond Blan I can't hear you
I'm sure you can go has anyone heard of
Raymond Blanc before it's based on that
but I it's based on Ray BL how dare you
come to the FW with all those French
fighting right now and you want to bring
in a chocolate fondant huh zero de yeah
so you got the egg yolks lightly whisked
and what's the egg white you take to
like a stiff peak or yeah o to a soft
Peak can you sit it on top of your head
I called yeah we're all right one that's
a brave we're right well done and if
they don't come out and they stick to
the mold you can blame the French is
that right that's right F chice that's a
brave move there you know that so Phil's
choice is the chocolate fondant which is
a very very brave choice because they're
so difficult to get right and you never
know when they're perfect and just until
you're about to serve them so when we
cook them in the restaurant we always
cook two just in case one's about to
claps or somewhat dry in the middle can
never happen in a restaurant now Danny's
playing it really safe he's just making
a very straightforward Plain Jane
pancake but I have to say I admire his
balls to keep it so simple what's inside
the pancake inside the pancake is going
to be vanilla poach pear uhhuh on top of
the pancake is going to be just like a
dark chocolate sauce so what you put in
there what have I put in there yeah
sugar one cup two vanilla pods fresh can
I um can I suggest you turn it down a
little bit poach P's poach not rapidly
boarding you still can't believe you
come in here with a French man's
recipe T dear let's hope that works
especially for you God especially for me
you know I love the
[Music]
French hello good to see you well you're
looking absolutely fantastic thank you
darling thank you you've been getting
bigger I know why is he going through
all the Motions has he been cooking for
you surely Rod can cook I mean he's man
of the world he can he um he does do a
good egg and do you have a sweet tooth I
mean do you like sort of chocolate Pond
that is my biggest downfall is is
chocolate does he ever take pudding to
bed not pudding to bed no I think he
doesn't like you know crumbs and things
we get messy but um just the last few
weeks I've been um having warm milk he
said got the week ago to me personally
it's actually going to be in the
birthing pool we might be bathing I
hope'll bathe before he gets in the
birthing pooling what going to be like
it's like a large jacuzzi and it's quite
yeah um and I believe that the water
will be up to about here you're both
going to be naked right he's going to be
well no I think I think he's going to
wear P trunks Speedos yeah good and now
it's been a bit of a manic week um this
then because um we been a debate about
sperm and how's Rod sperm well as you
can see he still got plenty of bullets
in his rifle as he puts all those years
of tight trousers and bloody leather
trousers with no pants so how does it
become so when we visited the doctor
last September when we were planning to
have Jan he did say because of our bir
of our ages that it could take some time
we were like okay well is there any
particular things we can do to help
loose loose pants so it was he was very
good he had showers only no bath bubble
bath um and and the loose pants we had
to go out and search for these you know
the boxes and things and we did we did
actually freeze this SP in case there
was going be problems oh okay later on
yeah of course at home we didn't do it
in in the hospital at home and then I
rushed down in the Ferrari with my
handbag with the little vial next to it
you know I felt like I was frozen sperm
have you any idea how expensive that ice
cube could be I know good to see you
babe lovely thank bye to me take care
good to see you thank
you it's the Moment of Truth for the two
commies and their
puddings they're both very different
desserts and they're going to be judged
by yeah the women's Institute of Fulham
John Baptist go with the pancake please
I'll take the chocolate fondant let's
go okay
ladies that is the chocolate fondant F
that looks very soft and just sort of
Falls away which is good but it's not
dry and crumbly so I think that's that
gives him a thumbs up I like the fact
it's not that sweet it's very very nice
it's actually not very heavy it's nice
and Light fascinated on the whole sort
of women's Institute becoming a younger
vibrant sexier sort of group what the
going
on well um I think there's a Resurgence
just like knitting's becoming cool the
wi is coming cool because we're much
more younger and I think we're coming
back to what you know being practical is
is sexy again but you don't look like a
lady from the wi for goodness well
that's good that we're flying the flag
let all
change second is it um a very simple um
poach pear um in a warm pancake the
presentation looks really
good the pears they're not crunchy tors
and yet they're not sloppy but they're
just the right texture and the chocolate
Nic well keep oh this is this is really
nice and the pancake is much really
lovely so like a vote um chocolate
fondant or crep I think the crap which
surprises me because normally I'm a
chocolate freak and I would absolutely
love it but actually the pears were
superb and I really enjoyed the crepe
crep ITP definitely the crep definitely
the crep definitely the CP the crep and
I don't even like pears it's going to be
five out of five CP zero dear definitely
it's the CP nigell orilia
yes meat or fish meat meat I get
fish fish and finally just before I go
me or
Jamie
oh ladies thank you cheers thank you
very
much well that was a lovely bunch of uh
wi members um from Fulham amazing ladies
um very constructive very critical um
the winning dessert yeah the dessert
that the diners are going to be eating
tonight is the pancake yeah well done
now thank you you haven't won the
overall thing however you're definitely
going to be serving your dessert tonight
and known you yeah you're going to take
it on the chin like a man and really
help this man with the dessert
that's right uh ladies I need some help
in the kitchen yeah you're all experts
right yeah okay let's go was up you no
not washing up little bit more exciting
than that you know that yeah I want some
real wi
pancakes go table legegg go you got two
more to come I need two more pancakes
followed by four more ladies yes did you
toss perfectly do it again for me show
me yeah you can fantastic now I need
five more portions ladies table eight so
how does that feel having the whole
dining room eating your dessert yeah
feels good you weren't compliment at all
no it's quite amazing what's just
happened you just served 60 customers
with your dessert and it shows how the
simple
tactic excuse me for God
s
I hear that people are still talking
about your get women back in the kitchen
campaign it seems to have hit a real
nerve and you know what some are really
happy and some people are really unhappy
but the most important thing they're
actually talking about it I'd rather
have a career than cook to be honest I
think it's nice for a woman to be able
to cook a really nice meal for a man to
come hunt at the end of the day I think
Gordon should s off for saying that his
shared responsibility busy Lifestyles
everybody's responsibility to do the
cooking in a household women or men it
doesn't matter who it is really people
should be cooking I think cooking is
very good it's very therapeutic how many
women know how to gut a chicken my
grandma could do it and I'd sit and
watch her well why should you have to
cook when you could buy it already cook
for you how many women know how to make
the money go further by making homemade
cakes rles whatever that is a lost do oh
I think he's absolutely right I mean my
wife I mean she wouldn't know what to do
with a meal
I mean everything's just Frozen from the
freezer into the into the microwave I'm
still receiving lots of requests of
women all over the country and um this
time I went to chesher to help two
Bridget
Joneses I'm Georgina and this is my
friend Naomi who's also my flatmate I
feel the fact that I can't cook is
really a social embarrassment now we've
got a lovely clean cooker and oven
lovely and clean cuz it doesn't get used
well there isn't much cooking done in
our kitchen but we do we are very well
stocked with cocktail glasses cocktail
shakers a blender for decaris cocktail
covered I want Gorden Ramsey to teach me
how to make a meal to impress a man
we're going to get two men round we're
going to cook them some food and we're
going to make sure that they are
impressed with our food why can't you
cook the reason I'm so bad at cooking is
because I had such a bad experience at
school I had a crookery teacher who was
mean and she picked on me every time I
made something it was wrong and she's
put me off for life you're both single
yes yeah what would you look for in a
man I like a nice tall blonde hunky
Viking type right
okay Rough and Ready and wrinkled this
is the cocktail cupboard bloody hell how
many cocktail shakers have you got three
what is that like something you stick on
the end of your boobs you stick that on
the end of a glass the place is more set
out like a cocktail bar as opposed to a
kitchen yes so um all jokes apart very
serious yeah um it's not good for me to
do this because you're going to be
cooking it okay but if I was coming
around here tonight for a date I'd
expect a good oldfashioned steak and
chips I want you to make the sauce for
the steak okay butter egg yolks and
taragan you with the chips pan of water
on bring up to the boil potatoes part
cooked taken out the water cut into
Quarters on a tray Rosemary little
garlic olive oil and they go in the oven
as the guys arriving okay should we get
cracking I know how to do it I know
you're supposed to do that the key to a
perfect Bonet sauce is to beat it well
and you just trickle the butter in there
like that and again don't
stop CH in get your fingers in there
good there you go good what's the most
important thing about cooking a steak
guessing what on it color right salt
pepper okay and you always season the
steak 2 minutes before it goes in the
pan in no I told you not to throw it in
there you're splashing it right now
we're getting color on it when when we
come to turn it over and in half of that
butter in please half half that's it now
the butter doesn't burn now if we put
the butter in first it will burn so the
steak gets black touch it good touch
right concentrate really concentrate
that's rare there's no bounce back
there's no balance look back into the
pan and I'm going to take it to medium
just put your fingers on top there and
touch that and notice there's some
spring it's coming back at you now it's
bouncing back up it's no longer rare in
the center all right so that is medium
that's a beautiful medium now we're
going to take it to medium well well
done and this is how my young Cooks
start learning how to cook steak
perfectly they close their eyes and they
guess how that steak's cooked close your
eyes I touch
them drain off the potatoes yeah have we
got some olive oil yes yeah cut the
potatoes in half in half again and then
we'll do each quarter in half again so
we've got the meal sorted out now we
just need some men to eat it cooking
with two ladies tonight actually teach
them how to cook y okay problem is they
got no fellas fancy dinner tonight we're
two beautiful girls I've got a
girlfriend got a girlfriend damn what
about you same time girlfriend I'm
afraid my girlfriend cook me balls off
like so sorry M okay because it's leol
Chelsea are there any single men in
whims wow wow wow Christ almighty that's
not bad we scrub it well you scrub it
very well five minutes right you
ready brought flowers indeed yeah they
come
[Music]
through okay yeah right now I think to
color like it is it good lovely
[Music]
color that looks nice let's stick the
salad on the side M that looks nice
steaking chips rocket parmesan salad
fresh lemon juice in there nice burn a
sauce on the side go for
it voila going have a tea that is
absolutely spot on below that we'll see
if it makes the the taste great hang on
10 out of
10 okay so far so good it's great well
done and just a personal message less
cocktails more cooking good night guys
have a nice evening and um I'll let
myself out okay good night bye bye bye
oh I need
St right Naomi and Georgina good to see
you please tell me you've done some
cooking since I've gone we have we've
done the duplicate meal actually haven't
we how how are the chips done oh they
were better weren't they they were
better un fantastic FR say nicer than
the ones we made with you not your did
you C off did it work did they did they
stay off but nice company had a good
night good night no romance but good
night um dating no but willing open to
office open to
off there is a Singleton here this
evening he's a ran critic I don't know
if you like sort of critics oh we we met
him yeah what do you
think what does that what does that mean
Liv in London see far away he's not he's
not a
viking I got to go now right hey get in
that kitchen stay in there yes and stay
away from the dacker
[Laughter]
is Right flipping heck um it's been a
it's been big news in in my kitchen and
um how's your sperm count my sperm
counts okay as far as I know and I
actually had um I had a bit of trouble
down there oh really yeah I had um an
operation um I had a a little kind of
cyst that I um on on your bollock on my
bollock I had assist and um as it
happened it was benign but I'm quite
happy to talk about it sorry because we
should talk about these things it's
really weird because over the last sort
of five or six years it's been brought
to my attention Yeah by my GP that I had
a very low sperm count because of
because of being in the kitchen the heat
in the kitchen when you look at the sort
of of high level of a stove nowadays
maybe the same thing for me by doing
game shows by resting against that lecon
perched on there huh family sperm Tunes
sperm tun it's all clear down there now
it's all good yeah it's all absolutely
good I'm so glad the sister's
gone the
sister the
Sister Sister let's keep up the cookie
cheers mate next the menu J spreads the
word about an up and cominging delicacy
come on people squirrel lovely squirrel
fresh squirrel it's
squirrel No you w kill your catch would
you if it was tasty I
might and we find out who's staying and
who's going home the person that I'd
like to stay in the F-word
[Applause]
kitchen welcome back to the f word the
future that's good enough to eat
so rumor has it you've actually found a
good possible source of cheap meat it's
it's better than cheap meat I found free
meat it's all around us I've been eating
squirrels squirrel for goodness sake
they're not edible they're
delicious yes yes he looks all lovely
and fluffy and sweet but he's not he's a
monster in my local park he strips the
bark from the trees in the countryside
he eats the eggs of song birds in my
garden he digs holes to hide his stupid
Acorn for the winter and worst of all he
has terrorized our native Red Squirrel
little squirrel nutkin into near
Extinction I hate gray
squirrels with Gray's outnumbering Reds
by 66 to1 conservationists last week
announced plans to eradicate all gray
squirrels in the vicinity of 16 newly
designated Red Squirrel reserves and
later this month the government plans to
publish a policy paper on gray squirrels
which may well include a new form of
squirrel
contraception that's one way of looking
at the gray squirrel problem but I've
got a better solution we could eat them
it may sound a bit disgusting if you've
never had squirrel before but I have and
it's delicious or at the very least it
is reasonably edible and as there's only
2 and 1 half million of them in Britain
it wouldn't take that many of us to
roast one up for Sunday lunch this
weekend to completely eradicate the gray
squirrel by the middle of next week and
create a lovely environment for our
little friend squirrel nutkin to make a
peaceful return to
Britain I want to prove just how tasty
squirrels are when expertly cooked so
I'm off to the butler Warf Chop House in
London one of the few restaurants that
has actually featured squirrel on its
menu mag you cook a squirrel uh
squirrels are quite small so we're going
to have to make sure he is a whole
animal so I'll I'll put you one down now
for you I can see you're taking off the
legs here yeah here we have the thigh of
the squirrel which is from all that
jumping around in the trees and you know
springing around it gets that's probably
got the most meat on it yeah we're going
to have to braze the legs because like
you said they've been jumping around in
the trees so these legs have done a lot
of work so here we've got the the saddle
with the two lines and the fillets ready
to be wrapped in bacon and roasted off
lovely tasty tasty just like eating
normal food marvelous got the two Hand
legs which we're going to braze off
serve as they are nice and me just like
having like a comfy duck leg in a a
rubbish High Street we've got the the
front legs the bellies the kidneys and
the livers which are all going to be
made into a nice little is the
challenging part that's all the little
bits that's the little front legs all
this little livers and kidneys the heart
and soul of the squirrel mashed up high
tasting quite smelly in a little pie
case it's the kind of thing I like not
for the
faint-hearted squirrel meat is very lean
it's low in fat and high in protein so
Craig's wrapping it in bacon to stop it
drying
out
right well just while I'm waiting for my
squirrel the some recommended a Coke d
own nice and fruity quite spicy s Gran
Ash blend very drinkable and will go
nicely he reckons with something as gy
as as an English squirrel Charles here's
your squirrel hope you enjoy yba daa
look at that little thighs for jumping
from Branch to Branch M
tasty oh that's wonderful that is the
taste of squirrel really taste of
English Woodland Oak trees and very easy
to eat
delicious well I've got some more cooked
squirrel and now all I need to do is
convince everybody else to eat it fresh
girl looks like chicken of
course but tastes a bit like cross
between pork and chicken it's not a
heavy taste it's very light I wouldn't
have thought a squirrel would have even
looked like that once it was cooked let
alone taste like that do you think
you'll be having it again um
it was all right it wasn't wasn't too
bad bit bit you know nutty
maybe damn it's like chicken it's a
little bit game
here quite a little bit greasy but in a
good way and um that's not pubic hair is
it no no no no that's squirrel hair
squirrels don't have pubic hair it's
squirrel oh no no you wouldn't kill your
catch would you if it was tasty I might
I don't know you think it'll catch on
could do probably
not it tastes really good it tastes kind
of similar to just don't say it taste
similar to chicken come on you got it's
kind of quail I thought when I ate it
yeah yeah you is it can you imagine can
you imagine buying squirrel and cooking
it yourself at home yeah I can I think
it's good so there you go people are
really pretty happy to eat squirrel and
so they should be it's a tasty and
nutritious way to get rid of the evil
gray and make an environment fit for
squirrel nutkin to return in trial so
the next time you're in your local park
and you see one of the Little Critters
running around don't think o little
furry friend think
lunch so will you beating them again
yeah they tasted all right and and if I
can get Rhythm from my garden then I
reckon two birds with one stone two
squirrels with one stone definitely so
is it legal it is legal uh if they're
causing damage if you have permission
from the landowner or you are the
landowner it is per permissible to to
shoot them and kill them um you have to
like all animals in Britain they're
protected from cruelty like any Wildlife
so you have to do it cleanly you can't
go around Ming squirrels for fun but
yeah absolutely
[Music]
leg